I'm Peter Russell I teach at UCLA and
Pepperdine and I'm here to talk today to
you about three amazing stories and I'm
gonna break down each one of them and
tell you what's great about it and the
first one I'm gonna start out with is a
great new television show in fact at one
Emmy of the best drama last year it's
called mr. robot and I'm really proud
one of my students has been in it just
really intimately involved in this story
from the beginning and I'm really proud
of him and I also want to talk about why
mr. robot as a television show has done
so well so when we look at a show a
television show it's very different from
a film in a lot of ways first of all we
need a hook that's gonna bring people
back for 100 episodes at least maybe 150
I have a manager he says Peter we got to
get 200 EPS whoever you're working with
we need to get 200 EPS because that's
when the big payoff comes but a hook in
television is different than a movie
it's what's gonna bring you back to the
story for episode after episode so what
is that in mr. robot
well the hook and mr. robot really is
this cyber vigilant a fighting against
these huge villains I mean if you have
credit card debt or if you have a school
debt then these villains are people you
can hate and part of the reason mr.
robots done so well with the young
demographic that it has is that so many
students and I have them at UCO and
Pepperdine they're in debt they're in
debt $100,000 or $200,000 and it's a
debt you can't get rid of you can't get
you can get rid of credit card debt you
cannot get rid of school debt so the
hook here for that audience and it's why
mr. robot is partly so popular is that
it's identifying the villain as a
villain that these people can hate and
that's going to bring them back for many
many episodes now what's the world here
it's the high tech world it's out of the
matrix and I often say in television if
you want to create a good original TV
show and I urge that you do because the
market now is roaring we've never had a
better time to teach to buy television
to sell television story we've gone from
250 to nearly 5
500 scripted shows in television in
America in the last five years
it is a boom so you want to have a movie
idea that you love and you want to twist
it slightly that's what mr. robot does
it twists the genre of The Matrix and it
makes it more modern
it's the cyber vigilante who is fighting
back against the system fighting back
against this incredible enemy so what's
the setting well it's New York that's
perhaps not its most important thing
it's most important attraction the theme
here is you can fight against the
biggest enemies in the world they are in
this case the finance company that run
the world the tone here is very real and
the tone is important in a television
show because if it's real you want to
make sure the show gives you real
genuine inside information and in mr.
robot that's what you get you get all
this great technology you really
understand how the internet works it
isn't just that horrible cliche in a
movie where somebody just goes oh we're
in and then that's the last you hear of
the computer technology it's all about
the computer technology it's very real
the character situation in a television
show needs to be one where it is a
permanent dilemma it's not resolvable in
one episode that's really important and
it's different from movies for instance
in Ashok I'd like Buffy the Vampire
Slayer which was a great show by Josh
Whedon Buffy's permanent dilemma is that
she is a she wants to just be a
cheerleader happy at a high school but
she has to kill vampires every week that
dilemma is never resolved when you have
a bad television show they don't do that
they simply give you a character that
you can resolve within a few episodes
it's no fun the permanent dilemma here
is that our hero is insane and he's also
never really going to be able to get
away from computers and from the
internet that's the way he fights the
villain but it's also the way that keeps
him alienated from the real world so we
have a fantastic permanent dilemma in
this show
we also have usually in a television
show a guy or a girl with a superpower
who is misusing that superpower at the
beginning of the pilot in Jessica Jones
she's misusing her superpower in even a
show like Mad Men Don Draper's misusing
his seductive ability to tell stories to
seduce women and to ruin families in
Breaking Bad we have a chemical genius
who is misusing his super power at the
beginning of the pilot he's not using
his chemical genius to do anything by
the end of the pilot he's using it for
malevolent purposes but he is using it
and so we also need characters who
fascinate and surprises so mr. robot has
all of this so what brings you back
every week to mr. robot is the same
thing that wrecks her back to man in the
high castle to making a murderer -
orange is the new black by the way what
is the big hook in orange is the new
black it's a great show done by a great
female showrunner the question that
brings you back is will Piper
ever figure out her sexuality and make
it out of prison and that's a permanent
dilemma because she never does she keeps
going back from men to women to men to
women and we want to watch and see if
she resolves that she never will most
great TV stories have this story
question at their Center and you need
that - what's the question in your
television show for Jessica Jones it's
will Jessica learn she can fight the
villain and win without losing her
ability to trust and love for Breaking
Bad it's how far as walter gonna break
bad the answer is insanely far so mr.
robot the question is will elliot be
able to take down the evil villain who
controls the world's entire banking
system a villain who enslaves nearly
everyone on the planet who has debt
that's a great question
and we're gonna see how by the way in
Game of Thrones is a very simple
question who is gonna win which family
is going to win the the throne and it
takes eight years ten years they say now
for that question to resolve itself okay
so we always have this in a great
television show we always do
the world here is not that great
breaking bad's is way better madman's is
the cool world of 60s sex in television
oranges new black what do you think that
is it's women in prison and it's very
sexy that's a great world mr. robots
world is the matrix but it's twisted
it's set in grunge hipster New York
Brooklyn New York and that also appeals
to its target audience right and the
venue matters too are you writing your
show for Network are you writing your
show for cable or are you writing your
show for Internet platform if you're
setting it for network it's gonna be
more tame but it also is ten times the
money if you're setting it for cable
you're making less money but you can be
far more free in what you show if you're
shutting it in the IP world you can show
anything right up to and including sex
and violence the content is twisted more
and more depending on the platform yes
now classic TV genres are just twists
that's what makes a modern television
show so take a television show you love
and twist it give it more sex give it
more violence or give it a appealing
villain that we can all hate mr. robot
is cable which means we can show nudity
we can show drug use we have a niche
audience right that means you can have
several plot storylines and your hero
can be darker than he might be in
network a lot darker and you can keep
him flawed and that's exactly what
Elliot is in mr. robot now remember in
television heroes don't heal they just
keep bleeding in a movie a hero will
heal by the end of the show
not so in television
you